así es el poroteo que es la palabra que
se usa aquí para el conteo de los votos
antes de que se dé la sesión daba
incluso en algunos momentos un empate
pero hubo unos algunos elementos clave
sobre todo el hecho de que un acuerdo al
inicio de la sesión de que el poder
ejecutivo hacer una modificación cuando
promueve esta ley un cambio de una
palabra no va a hablar de salud integral
sino de salud en los casos en que se
sigue permitiendo el aborto más allá de
las 14 semanas de gestación que es algo
similar a lo que ya existe no está el
aborto voluntario sino que es el legal
en casos específicos como violación o de
salud riesgo para la vida de la madre no
será más salud integral como estaba en
el proyecto original sino que el poder
ejecutivo lo cambiara a salud y eso
permitió que algunos senadores que
estaban indecisos cambiaran su voto de
hecho fue muy contundente el cambio 38
votos fue lo que tuvo en 2018 el senado
el rechazo de una ley similar así que
podemos decir que claramente el senado
se dio vuelta en esta en esta nueva
legislatura y cambió radicalmente su
voto porque la diferencia es muy
importante nueve votos de diferencia no
es menor en un senado que tiene setenta
y algo de banca digo setenta y algo
porque hubo ausentes en esta ocasión
algo que también jugó a favor de la
aprobación de esta iniciativa
legislativa